time then for the press preview our
first look at the front pages
as they come into us here at sky and
tonight we'll see what's making the
headlines with the parliamentary sketch
writer madeline grant
and the author and journalist rachel
shabby nice to see you both this sunday
evening speak to you
in a moment first of all let's take you
through some of those front pages
starting
with the metro the uk faces pressure to
put india on the red list after it
recorded
more than 261 000 covid cases in just
one day the sun has a picture of prince
william and prince harry together at the
duke of edinburgh's funeral
saying that the brothers are united in
grief
loneliest birthday is the headline for
the male as the queen prepares to
mark her first birthday without her
husband for
70 years
in the guardian a senior police leader
has said that cutting
poverty and inequality is the best way
to reduce
crime the eye reports that the former
president of the european commission
jean-claude juncker has accused david
cameron of incompetence
and the ft leads on a pledge between the
u.s and china who have committed to work
together on climate change
boosting hopes for a new global
emissions deal
this year and as i say i'm joined
tonight by madeleine grant and rachel
shabby good to see you let's start shall
we with the front
of the metro rachel
a lot of pressure isn't there to put
india on the red list at the moment
it isn't on the red list people can come
back
into the united kingdom as long as
they've had the relevant tests they have
to self-isolate at home but they don't
have to go into
a quarantine hotel many of people are
saying that needs to change given the
horrific
situation in india at the moment what
are your thoughts rachel
yeah that's right as you say india is
having an absolutely
awful time with covet at the moment
over 261 000 cases recorded in one day
and as you say the pressure is mounting
for india to be placed on that red list
of countries so there are
39 countries currently i believe on that
list
which means that um travel to the uk is
restricted only to uk nationals
and you have to go into quarantine hotel
for 10 days
upon arrival and as some people have
noted there are countries with
fewer daily infection numbers
that are on that list so the question is
why
india is not yet and it's obviously
thought to be tied
to the fact that boris johnson plans to
go on a trade visit
uh to visit with the indian prime
minister narendra modi
um and is therefore um you know
avoiding putting the country on the red
list
in not unrelated reasons but it does
seem to fit a pattern doesn't it
boris johnson uh constantly constantly
doing things too slowly uh resisting
um calls for him to act immediately and
you would think by now
he would have learned the lesson of
doing that and the cost of doing that
to the country but it appears that he is
dragging his heels on this one as well
yeah madeline do you think that uh that
politics is at play here that's why
india hasn't been put on the on the red
list i mean we should say of course the
government has said that it is scaling
down it's
it's a prime ministerial visit to in
india it's not going to do what it
originally planned
yeah it's politically it's very
difficult i mean for example
pakistan and bangladesh are on the red
list and india is not
and it's not just tricky because of the
pm's upcoming visit to india
it's also i imagine because so many
british british citizens have
family in india and when you shut the
borders to that you were effectively
shutting down family life for a very
large number of people so
you know you could imagine politicians
not wanting to pull that press that
switch
you know not taking that not taking that
decision too lightly
um even though the stakes are so
incredibly high i mean i imagine that
the absolute worst case scenario that
politicians will be
and of course general public and public
health authorities will be
worried about is um you know even though
the strain that we're talking about is
still
a variant under investigation and not a
variant of concern which is slightly
different there is this fear that a
vaccine resistant virus strain could
become
the kind of could sweep through the
country and become the predominant one
and therefore setting back um all of our
vaccination effort efforts so high so
the stakes are incredibly high
and the politics are very tricky and i
don't i don't see this um this story
going anywhere because i think the fear
of
a new strain emerging onto the scene is
is something that
is very paramount to the minds of the
british public
okay uh let's move on to a completely
different story front page of the
financial times
rachel this story breaking earlier on
today about top clubs
forming this european super league
um it is a concern for for many
we know that um the the premier league
has come out to condemn it um
and uh even the prime minister tonight
yeah it's provoked absolute fury and
outrage and
you can kind of see why this is a plan
for a uh super league
of 12 major european clubs including uh
big six
from the uk so including liverpool manu
man city chelsea
tottenham and uh arsenal
and it's like these clubs
um and of course this is seen as you
know pitting the fans against
the the elite club managers and it's
provoked
outrage across the board but it's almost
like the clubs have looked
at football and gone well this
competitive sport
the bit that is present preventing us
from making
even more millions than we already do is
the competitive bit so why don't we just
take that away
and it's just obviously absolutely
incensed fans who've gone but you're
actually gonna
completely destroy the game just for the
sake of greed
so it's it's small wonder that it's
provoked such
an incredible backlash um from fans
and also from uefa which is uh saying
that it's now going to try and use
all measures uh to try and prevent what
it describes as a
cynical project from taking place
where do you stand on this madeleine i
don't know if you're a big football fan
but football in england is all about
dreams
isn't it it's about football fans
knowing that the club that they support
on a saturday through good times and bad
times could
just maybe one day get to play the very
best teams
in europe um and and it's almost like
this this isn't about that is it it's
not about dreams it's about making money
well that's exactly it and i i don't
claim to know much about football at all
but
i could see this decision seriously
backfiring in the sense that as you say
one of the great joys of football is how
unpredictable it is i think it is
actually
often different from other sports in
fact that there is quite often a quite
high level
of unpredictability you get these
situations where
underdogs can cause big upsets you know
like when
leicester won the premier league or even
um a few years ago when iceland did so
well in the world cup
you know how incredible were these
sporting moments but when you turn the
the game into a kind of
elite little club for existing champions
you know it will ultimately take away
um much of that allure i think however
fun it might initially be to see some of
the very best players tussling it out
at the highest level um and i also
wonder if there might be an element of
i suppose it's a form of protectionism
almost from some of the best clubs
who've been
you know liverpool's not had a good
season um
i wonder if there may be an element of
protectionism almost to try and keep out
competitions from
the lower ranked teams that on a good
day could well end up beating some of
these top clubs
interesting uh that story going to
develop i'm sure over the next 24 hours
i just want to move on quickly because
we're running short of time
um why don't we stay with you madeline
just look at the front page of the eye
they've got an exclusive with
jean-claude juncker there's a name we've
not heard for some time
yes it's it's they have an interview in
which um he's
as evil juncker has um decided to give
his
his take on um the state of affairs and
as always with
young committees there was not a shred
of self-awareness um
he's taken the kind of evergreen
opportunity to have the dunk on david
cameron
but alongside his complaints that david
cameron was not he
didn't feel he could trust him when they
were speaking together before the 2016
referendum
um the thing that really tickles me is
his his apparent belief that um
that with further intervention from eu
luminaries such as himself
um they could have swung the referendum
result in favor of remain
um which is just a wonderfully um
wonderfully delusional view but
in fact we know that we know that the
opposite is true i mean when
barack obama um came out batting for the
remain side and bear in mind that he's
someone who
already commanded huge levels of trust
and respect from the british public
um the evidence suggests that it had
exactly the opposite effect on people's
um voting intentions so i know when i
read this interview
i almost wonder if it's you know what
has been learnt from the experience of
brexit it seems to be that you know they
don't really
they still don't really understand why
brexit happened they don't accept any
degree of kind of responsibility or sort
of interest introspection as to why the
public
might have voted that way it's all kind
of they were lied to
and actually what we needed was more um
more kind of pontificating from brussels
rachel yeah i mean
if juncker wants to call um
camera and david cameron incompetent and
untrustworthy he can
join the back of a very long queue of
people
who are doing that um i do think there's
a grain of truth in what he's saying
about
um the need during that 2016
uh referendum campaign to make the cause
for the eu i don't think that was done
sufficiently but i don't think he would
have been a great
message carrier for that particular
campaign
um and uh yeah so perhaps he is lacking
in self-awareness to see that
but certainly that was something that
was missing
from the campaign and i'm i'm sure there
are a lot of people with that same kind
of
hindsight over it okay so a full ranging
interview
uh he also talks about uh not being an
alcoholic he says those
accusations hurt me i've never been
drunk in my life you can read more
uh in the eye newspaper thank you both
for the moment
coming up there's new hope for a new
global emissions deal this year between
the u.s and china
we'll be discussing that after the break
welcome back part two of the press
preview parliamentary sketch writer
madeline grant and the author and
journalist rachel shabby
still with us um financial times front
page madeline let's start with you this
time u.s china
climate pledge boosts hopes for global
emissions deal tell us about this
yes uh this is the news that um the u.s
and china have kind of
have put out a have made a commitment of
sorts to work together
to tackle climate change um john kerry
who is the the us environmental envoy
and his opposite number in china
have put out a joint statement um vowing
to cooperate on reducing emissions
and i mean that's quite a big deal
because
in the sense that climate change is
perhaps the one area of public policy
where
we do unambiguously have to work with
china to solve the problem
um and you know it's good to see some
positive noises coming out of that but i
i to me it doesn't seem to mean very
much in reality beyond a kind of broad
um statement of intent uh it's not a
guarantee to fix anything
as we know china doesn't really have any
problem going back on
much more binding agreements than this
can we be more optimistic rachel do you
think as we head towards
cop 26 at the end of the year i mean
it's worth pointing out that the us all
pulled out the paris accords it's not
like either country has a great track
track record but um both countries
combined do account for
40 of the world's pollution so both of
them together
uh do have a lot of work to do and a lot
of responsibility for leading the way
um it remains to be seen what they can
do together i think madeline's right
that it is
at the moment just a declaration with
not much substance
uh biden has announced a big
uh climate proposals um part of which is
premised on
um you know massive rollout for uh
electric vehicles part of which is about
reaching um carbon zero
uh relying relying on energy sources
that are carbon zero
to power the country uh so that those
two things combined
are massive but of course climate
activists in the us
are saying that even that doesn't really
go far enough it's too slow it's paced
over 10 years
we don't have that kind of time
meanwhile looking over to china um
they're one of they're one of the
leading uh global
sort of culprits for things like
deforestation
and still using coal-fired energy
so both countries have got a lot of way
to go
uh and they do also shoulder a lot of
the responsibility for the crisis that
we're currently in
indeed okay and let's finish with the
front of the daily mail
uh madeline uh rather sad front page
isn't it loneliest birthday the queen
without philip for the first time in
seven decades her birthday on wednesday
she's going to be 95. i guess the best
present she could hope for
is also reflected on the front page
there perhaps charles being able to
reunite
william and harry yeah
front page and i really i thought
nothing could top the the kind of
the tragedy of the images of the queen
at the duke of edinburgh's funeral
sitting alone and separated from her
family but the story in the mail has
possibly
achieved it you know the idea that a
grieving widow has to spend her
95th birthday alone with only a kind of
a small bubble of her
staff members there to keep her company
and it's the sort of nasty
traumatic situation that so many
families across britain have had to go
go through over the last year but doubly
compounding the
grief of losing your husband of 70 years
is the fact that there is this
ongoing feud between um princess william
and harry
and um you know i suppose some people
might have seen it as
i think they were exchanging some words
at the funeral so perhaps there are
signs of reproduction
but what from what the male seems to be
suggesting is still quite a long way off
um achieving that um and perhaps prince
charles is the one
is the one to do it yeah rachel um
sources telling the mail that a
meaningful reconciliation between the
brothers was still
some way off i mean the truth is none of
us know do we
how their relationship is no
i mean only the people in a relationship
know truly how the relationship is
but i do think there's some there is
something very poignant about
uh having a birthday so close to
bereavement i think because there has
been so much
grief in this country over the last year
so many lives lost
a lot of people will be able to relate
to that um
and you know have a sort of emotional
resonance with that idea because of
course
um you know those special days
things like you know holidays christmas
easter
birthdays anniversaries um are really
difficult
uh when you're grieving because you're
reminded
of the bereavement and so to have that
one of those occasions
land so closely after a bereavement i
think
is is a particularly tough one yeah
really really
tough uh rachel madeline thank you both
very much indeed we'll see you again in
half an hour